all right thank you all for joining us
as you may know immediately following
this panel we have a performance from
yo-yo ma over lunch which were very
excited about but I for one and I hope
you are as well
equally excited if not more excited
about this panel the topic of this panel
is going to be on a eyes impact on
economic inequality in class and we have
some excellent speakers here to share
their thoughts with you today my name is
Johnny Penn I'm gonna be the host I'm an
affiliate at the Berkman Kline Center on
Harvard University and a PhD candidate
the University of Cambridge and I'm also
the project development lead on the
history of a history of AI project at
the center for the future of
intelligence in Cambridge I just had a
stroke so just to give you a quick
overview of what we're gonna do we're
gonna have a format this the format will
be 30 minutes our speakers will share
with you their thoughts on this topic
and we'll walk through a couple
questions and have them speak to each
other ideally and then we're gonna open
the floor to you for 30 minutes to share
your thoughts on on this tour to ask
questions about this topic now it may
not need to be said but I'm gonna say it
anyways that we are in a point now of
historic inequality two-thirds of the
world's wealth 1% of the global
population is on track to have
two-thirds of the world's wealth by 2030
and the ways that this trickles down
into real harm to people dying to people
in in in misery is hard to quantify it's
hard to even Express sometimes and is I
think we need to constantly remind
ourselves of the world the amount of
inequality that we are suffering through
now to give you just a quick example in
Nova Scotia we learned this week 600
employees at a call center were fired
just before Christmas including one man
Justin who had been there for 14 and a
half years and was sent back to his two
kids unable to pay his electrical bills
and had to tell his two kids that they
would not only not be able to pay for
electricity but not be able to be able
to pay for rent as well this is not
gonna this is not a unique situation
this is going to be happening more as
more as this next wave of automation
takes off and so we collectively have to
think through what we're going to do to
deal with that
to give you a brief introduction to our
speakers and we have one final speaker
is going to join us her flight is
slightly delayed but she will rush up
onto the stage and and and and speak to
you
the first joining from Los Angeles
California can we hear you Sophia can
you hear me yes fantastic okay you your
that your the position of kind of God
speaking to the rest of us
dr. Sophia John Noble I'm sorry I've got
the pronunciation wrong is the assistant
professor at the University of Southern
California's Annenberg School of
Communication and the author of the
best-selling an incredible book
algorithms of oppression how search
engines reinforce racism and dr. Nobles
research focuses on racist and sexist
algorithmic bias and commercial search
engines and I encourage you to follow or
on Twitter and to read her work but also
to follow her on Twitter right now next
we have here beside me John havens who
is executive director of the IEEE
Tripoli's Global Initiative on the
ethics of autonomous and intelligent
systems which has two primary outputs
the first is the creation and iteration
of a body of work known as the ethically
a lot known as ethically aligned design
a vision for prioritizing human
well-being with autonomous and
intelligent systems and the
identification and recommendation of
ideas for standards projects focused on
prioritizing ethical considerations in
such systems you can follow John on
Twitter as well we have a surprise
addition to this panel which is dr.
Kristina Koch off who is the director
for the future of work at uni global
Union uni global Union represents 650
unions worldwide and and I'm very glad
to have a union voice on this panel and
the final speaker who will be joining us
from the airport she's racing here now
from there is dr. if yo maroon WA who is
assistant professor at Cornell
University's industrial and labor
relations school associated faculty
member at Cornell Law School faculty
associate at the Berkman Kline Center at
Harvard Law School and dr. Arun was
research interests lie the intersection
of law and technology with a particular
focus on organizational behavior and the
ethical governance of workplace
technology so one thing I would love to
accomplish in this panel is to be plain
spoken about the situation we're in and
to not
- do not need to feel that you need to
hold back your emotions in any way
because I think there's reason to be
incensed with the situation we're in but
I I would be like to hear your opinion
so to start us off John I guess you
travel the world talking to engineers of
many different kind of technical
backgrounds what do you see as the
responsibilities that engineers have in
this in this position
none at all okay that's kidding so first
I should say just to be outspoken or
what have you of the views I'm sharing
today just to be disclaimer ish our mind
our John's
and don't necessarily represent my
Triple E and that way I can speak more
openly up the work that we're doing is
actually all about complimenting
engineers I Triple E is the world's
largest technology Association it's the
heart of the global engineering
community created by Thomas Edison about
130 years ago it's in 160 countries with
over half a million members so first of
all I am honored to be working with
engineers I am NOT an engineer and the
joke I've been making with my
philosopher and marketing friends the
last three years or so of this work has
been who do you want building your
elevator the engineers or the ethicists
as a rule the engineers but then the
metaphor which may be too forced is you
want the ethicists and we're not so long
for the ride yeah it's pretty bad but
it's it's early forgive me I think the
thing about responsibility is also to
turn that question around and say how
can we help in the sense of I think it's
unfair that engineers you know when
you're not necessarily and and it's it's
hard to talk about engineers just like
one small group right it's such a vast
realm but to say you're responsible for
everything that happens with X product
when the product that's released
downstream may be something you don't
touch in certain manifestations earlier
on so our focus and again sponsored by
or helped supported by I Triple E is to
complement the work of that engineers
have done since the time the aqueducts
earlier and say along with things like
focusing on harm and focusing on
decreasing unintended consequence
how can you also ask other questions
about the values of the end users who
are using the products and this also
affects market decisions any that's a
kind of boring way to start but that's
that's my first answer Thank You
Jonathan and I'm just gonna pick up
John's book artificial intelligence
heart is in heart it's available on
Amazon now if you're interested so
professor Noble to move to you what do
you think
artificial intelligence how do you how
do you characterize the impact that
artificial intelligence is a suite of
technologies will have on class and
economic inequality just honor to have
an opportunity to join this panel and to
speak to you all of you and I have so
much respect for the work of Engineers
even though sometimes maybe I'm not
characterized as such I think that the
decisions as John said that engineers
are engaged in in terms of automating a
whole host of decisions and outcomes are
incredibly important and of course
they're playing a role in the
organization of our economy you know we
can look at for example one of the
things I try to do in my book is gather
enough evidence and examples to show how
there are kind of a whole host of ways
and contexts and histories and
communities within which digital
technologies are operating and in some
cases they're really exacerbating social
inequality certainly at a level of
whether it's misrepresenting people in
ensnaring people into systems that maybe
they don't want to be the targets of not
giving people a way out of some of these
and I'll give you an example you know
one of the things that I've been
concerned about and kind of in tracking
are the ways that old patterns of
discrimination become the datasets upon
which machines are trained and
technologies are based digital
technologies and the way they're
deployed and so for example if you look
at for for so many years women and girls
their identities have been sexually
exploited women and girls often find
themselves characterized as sexual
objects in search engines that's not new
to the internet although the internet
certainly amplifies these kinds of ideas
about women and girls and that of course
becomes worse when you are a woman or a
girl of color there are also all kinds
of new technologies in Karen and Los
Angeles which is one of the epicenters
of technologies like predictive policing
for for example and we see you know
again and the kinds of histories of over
policing communities of color over
policing poor people and these become
the data sets that serve as a baseline
for example in predicting who future
criminals will be and I find this really
interesting that you know the context
within which we think about crime and
criminality is one that is deeply
racialized in this country for example
you don't see predictive policing
technologies facing Wall Street and some
of us might say that would be a really
important place to look and see where
criminality is going down and of course
if we had had those kinds of
technologies maybe facing other sectors
of our economy and of our societies we
might have predicted that Wall Street
makers would be engaged in the worst
financial crisis of you know of my life
certainly in modern history which is
market
2006 wherein we had the largest transfer
of wealth from black communities back to
the hands of white communities in the
United States and then the largest wipe
out of black wealth in the history of
the United States
so effectively all of the gains of the
civil rights movement all the way back
to the construction were destroyed
during that crisis and that was really
an automated you know financialization
and gamification of the markets series
of processes that were implicated in
that and those are the kinds of things
that I think are really important you
know I've often taught computer science
students and actuarial science students
and when I try to teach them for example
the history of breath mining and how
redlining is implicated they need to
understand this history and how that
might get recreated in the digital
systems I've had actuarial science
students say to me why do I need to know
about this they really don't understand
how these datasets and how these
previous histories become a baseline for
the kinds of financial modeling that
they're doing in the future and this is
one of the reasons why he gets so
important that social scientists and
engineers are in communication thank you
very much and again we're gonna open the
floor to questions if any of you guys
want to follow up on individual ideas
that have come up I'm very glad to have
our final panelists with us dr. fu oh ma
Jun wah now you're an expert in the
history of labor relations and I wonder
if you could help us understand how this
moment in time characterized this moment
of time in the kind of passing of
history what's unique about this moment
and what is what sort of trends have
been building that work this weekend
past one there we go
but that's a really great question right
because it's you know as Sofia was
noting you know a lot of these things
that we're seeing now were things that
were set in motion in the past and it's
really all about how automation has
exacerbated their effects and I think
the same is true in labor relations so
when you look at things like for example
hiring out
rhythms they're really operating on
age-old stereotypes age-old racial
categorizations and age-old racial
hierarchies that we already sit in
please
the difference of course is that they
can operate at a velocity and a volume
that's much different than any one human
manager right so the effects are much
much more impactful much much more
widespread and can also become much more
entrenched because of the sort of aura
of impartiality and objectivity that we
impart to machines right and because of
that the results may go on own
questioned versus when a human manager
is returning results that might seem
bias then there's more likely to be a
question of oh why is it that you know
we haven't hired any people of color or
we haven't hired any women versus when a
machine is running the results I feel
that as a society we kind of have a
tendency to be too trusting that the
machine knows at all or that the machine
is somehow removed from the history of
visualization particularly I think in
the United States so I think that is
something that I am really trying to
bring to the forefront in terms of
Liebherr relations just thinking through
how the use of machines in the workplace
which may be seen as progressive or
innovative me nonetheless be reinforcing
inequalities or creating new ones so
John you wanted to respond to that are
we able to get the rest of these mics up
please John you wanna respond sure by
the way nice to meet you I'm glad your
flight okay I just want to say thank you
so fiha it's such a pleasure to meet you
at least virtually ask God it's nice to
meet God and some of the stuff you said
I wanted up I guess take it maybe in a
different direction
to comment on the mortgage crisis so
again I'm speaking as John so
technically I'm the consultant I was an
actor for about 15 years in New York
I've always lived as a consultant unless
an American where health insurance is
not guaranteed
I have kids on the average amount of
debt that most Americans will face when
they leave college is $30,000 if they're
lucky and what I didn't understand after
the mortgage crisis ended was how no one
was punished and I'm not interested in
being condemned natori for the sake of
being condemnatory
I'm not you know like angry about those
people should be punished in the sense
of politics and I'm not interested in
talking Republican versus Democrat or
what have you or anything about any
administration I just don't understand
what I do why people weren't punished
what I do understand what I'm living and
so many of my friends are living is one
medical bill one four five thousand
dollars can ruin many people I know and
I don't mean ruin like Oh tough year
this year can't buy you know certain
type of clothes at Christmas I mean move
your house how many people have friends
and if I'm alone I am shocked maybe it's
because we're in Canada how many friends
over the course of the mortgage crisis
had discussions with their friends and
family what they said in one fell swoop
and one week we lost half of our
retirement savings and those are people
who even had access to things like 401ks
or when you leave a job to actually even
have the phrase severance package I want
to be very conscious of the fact and be
and say with as much honor and respect
as I can to Sofia and to my fellow pet
literally a Foom
ofoma I'm also keenly aware that I'm a
49 year old white guy I have more
privileges than most people on the
planet so I want to be very clear about
my bias nonetheless as a father with two
kids living right now in a place where
two things I don't understand
one
people don't get punished when they pre
meditatively break the law then kind of
all bets are off with fully
understanding how to build anything let
alone AI which is so you know easy to
help wonderfully with things like
statistical modeling or whatever else
but I'm also glad that Sophia brought up
the fact that a lot of the basis for
automation in terms of how things can
harm us sadly have started with the
primary way that people gauge value on
the planet still which is basically
exponential growth through GDP GDP is
not evil but it's one very myopic set of
things to measure about value or values
its productivity and growth the other
thing I'll mention quickly even go on a
separate talk if you want is tax evasion
sexy to talk about on an AI for a good
panel but tax evasion means that
whatever organization wants to do it
billions sometimes trillions of dollars
just moves money kind of from left to
right is it legal yes is it ethical not
at all and by the time you want to talk
about the money that will make doing
this and that and all these are the
great stuff awesome
making money cool but when you are able
to move billions and trillions and
dollars around and then again the middle
and lower class from any background
continues to suffer then AI for good
becomes a strange sort of phrase I keep
saying it's actually AI for goods with
an S because the focus is on product and
productivity it is not on the
environment or building purpose thank
you John
so Sofia I want to respond or I would
love for you to pick up on this in just
a sec but first because dr. Knopf if you
would introduce for us how what role do
unions plan this we've seen that Google
had this you know twenty three twenty
thousand person walkout that that
affected real change and so people that
are at these big companies now can
affect real change but what is your
position as a unionist on on this other
I know first of all I really want to
thank all of you in this room for being
here I realized that AI for social good
is maybe not a typical topic of this
Congress but to see so many of you here
that's great so what are unions doing
some would say hopefully nothing some
would say that unions were bracket in
history we have our hay days and that's
it but I think that search for the
collectiveness the search of the
awareness now that something is a shift
something something's wrong I want to
ask all of you in this room who in here
has a job in a company how many of your
worker now it's funny there's much fewer
workers and they're people in the
company and this is precisely the
problem we have been taught to believe
we're something different than a worker
but you are workers every single one of
you who has a job in a company you are
worker even those of you who also might
drive an uber or might be a contractual
worker or might be forced to be
self-employed or on a zero-hour contract
you are workers and one of the problems
of our times is we've come to believe
with something different than that or as
a young woman in Sao Paulo said to me a
couple of weeks ago when I gave a speech
there she said I know what's wrong with
unions and I said I said you are for the
workers but nobody is a worker anymore
and I think this is something we have to
consider when we're talking about
technology of all of you who claimed you
did work in a company how many of you
have access to the data that the company
has on you do 3.the this just goes to
show the information asymmetry at the
moment is putting us as workers and 99%
of you in this room are workers in a
position of disadvantage how are we
supposed to negotiate the algorithm if
we don't have access to the same
information the same data that the
operations have so what role do the
unions have while one of these is one of
the ones I'm working hardly on across
the world is how do we get access to
this data how do we start putting
demands to what data they are allowed to
log on us I have read many multinational
companies data policies they want to
lock in people's gender sexuality why
trade union membership is specifically
mentioned why and I think this is where
we have to start reflecting where why am
I in a position of information asymmetry
in a world that is supposed to be giving
us equal access to information the free
internet so this is why we're seeing I
think Johnny to answer your question is
rising up war of people we don't need a
traditional Union necessarily to run
that I get infused by the collectives
that are being built and nobody should
said that solidarity is dead we will and
all of you in this room who are workers
you will reclaim your position thank you
all of you so Sofia you know you're
involved in this in the AI community
you've seen the spread of kind of AI
ethics as a way to respond to some of
the excesses of the system in which this
technology or this kind of science is
embedded how do you characterize the
winners and losers and how do you
characterize AI epics as a kind of
solution to these some of these problems
and you know we could have a whole
conference that was just about these
conversations rather than a short hour
you know I think one of the things
that's that's interesting to me
especially kind of building off the last
couple of comments is the way in which
we'd come to characterize ourselves and
the users of the Internet so one of the
things we know for example I mean I'm
I'm super old I was on the internet
before there was a graphic user
interface before
that's cable for Al Weber and PBS's so
I've been around for a minute and you
know in early internet culture as
utopian as it was imagined and you can
certainly take out some critiques of
that we thought of ourselves as netizens
in a different way you know we thought
of ourselves as kind of organizing
around a whole host of interest and of
course now how people who use the
Internet or thought of as users and
consumers and commodities data objects
to become modified by platforms and
that's of course you know one way of
thinking about what digital technologies
could do what they could provide it
could have been different
quite frankly and for those of us who've
been around for a long time we know that
there are lots of different ways we
could have gone rather than the
full-blown commercial internet you know
and and I think that what we've seen is
that the Internet has just become
another site for organizing capital and
extracting you know resource or
extracting value out of human beings and
of course it's done this in some of the
most egregious ways and we're reading
about that and have liens all of the
time so I think these are the kinds of
things that are starting to be taken up
by people who talk about for example
an AI and of course we're in a piano
here called AI for social good and one
of the things that I try to just you
know I appreciate that we are for
grounding ethics I do think it's a very
narrow conception of the problems it
centers the technology still as if
perfecting the technology this kind of
techno deterministic impulse that people
just seem to not be able to resist that
if we could just make them more perfect
more ethical less discriminatory
algorithm or AI then our problems would
be solved but these problems are not
going to be solved they're technical
solutions and like the previous speaker
I think they're gonna has has said so
beautifully we need to be thinking about
how we want our society to be organized
and in whose interest and what world
would witnessing is the use of kind of
the financialized information alized
data fight markets and processes that
are becoming more and more opaque to see
massive transfers of wealth I mean we've
seen the greatest transfers of wealth
from working people to you the 1% over
the last 10 years
and we could even say these since the
1970s come under the auspices of
neoliberal social economic economic
policy and and you know people just
think they're kind of playing with a nap
or making a nap or you know I mean
there's a lot at stake in the making
these kinds of game appliance systems
that obscure in many ways and also
acculturate us to things like a gig
economy as if we would want to spend our
lives in precarious in precarity driving
uber or doing some other type of
work where we should be grateful to have
you know car Lords I don't know I think
of that as like kind of the landlords
the people who we can own who own of the
cars that we lease so that we can drive
and you know not have health care right
or not have any network day and not have
benefits that organized labor helped us
to achieve and they can glorify it as
like something new in an innovative and
those are the discourses creativity gig
innovative and I think we got a press
pause on that and double-click on that
and say wait a minute that's what's
happening is a rollback of labor rights
a rollback of worker security a rollback
of any type of access to the middle
class I mean my grandparents did better
than my husband and I are doing in terms
of real net wealth how can that be I
mean my my grandparents were working
blue-collar workers and my husband and I
are white-collar workers and we can
barely live in LA so we have to look at
like these things like you tell me that
you opened up South with which is the
transfer of wealth through consolidation
of power in the hands of the elites and
what our active role will be in either
persisting that like Walker said people
like workers at Microsoft are attempting
to do and saying like we won't go any
further than this line we won't cross
this line but also understanding the
work that they need in the world and how
that's either accelerating these
problems or or intervening upon and
disrupting thank you very much so
if you might have one question for you
and then I'm gonna open the floor to the
audience I'm curious about like to what
extent is this is really about AI
because this seems like a bigger problem
so is it really fair to put the pressure
on you know those of us in the AI
community to deal with this and the
other part of this is you know I've got
a laptop when I use Amazon and I have
things that capitalism gives me that I
really like so when we talk about this
are we talking about overthrowing
capital I don't you know
how do you characterize the strategic
kind of way we in this community can
engage with the parts that are most
relevant to this community well I mean
I'll start by first reiterating really
what Sofia mentioned which is you know
this idea of techno determinism and what
I see as the perils of techno solution
ism which is that technology is a
solution to the problem of Technology
and that's framing the problem as you
know Sofia so eloquently put it quite
narrowly the problem isn't just the
technology the problem is the belief
systems ethos that went into the design
of the technology the problem is the
design of our society and why we think
such technology is needed in the first
place
so I really do want to stress that
techno solution ISM can't be the only
answer we really have to look further
and I also wanted to touch upon the idea
of ethics in AI you know there's been an
upswell rate of people clamoring for
more ethics in terms of how you know
people like you do your work you know
how engineers and developers are you
know look at products that they're
working on and then there's also been a
subsequent sort of backlash in terms of
people thinking well is that putting too
much on the workers right because at the
end of the day I think there's a
realization that the workers and the
company only have so much say in the end
product right they are giving marching
orders and they're constrained to those
marching orders so even if you have the
most ethical engineer the most ethical
software developer they're still
constrained by their organizational
structure so that I think really tells
us that ethics can't also be the only
civil
and I'm for ethics I teach ethics and
technology at Cornell and I really do
think that ethical curriculum and
ethical training should be like a
required part of any professional
training you shouldn't be something
that's discretionary or something that's
more of an elective as it is in many
places currently all that being said
however as a lawyer I want more laws I
want something with teeth the problem
you know at the end of the day is that a
lot of that thanks for most people it
feels like you know it's something I can
add on I'll take or leave it whereas
laws right with real consequences real
criminal penalties or monetary
liabilities would have teeth so I really
think that we want laws to protect
workers for example I think some
existing laws can be read to protect
workers even in the light of new
technological developments like for
example hiring algorithms there are some
consumer laws that could be read to
protect workers who make use of them but
that being said I also think that some
of the laws you know they didn't
envision the current technologies when
they were being promulgated so that does
mean that we do need to rethink some of
the laws and it might not be rewriting
the laws but perhaps we're thinking
their application we're thinking burdens
of proof etc so I guess that's my
long-winded answer to your question as
to whether you know this is really just
about technology or capitalism in of
itself I think that's a part of question
that we still want to ask right we still
we don't want to just say oh this is a
bad algorithm let's just create another
one we should ask oh well why was this a
bad algorithm why was this not a
solution to a problem was
problem existing in the first place and
I think this is especially true when you
have algorithms that have social
economic impact right like hiring
algorithms for example you know you had
the recent snafu with Amazon and it's
hiring algorithm that seemed to you know
be biased against women because of
certain characteristics that have been
written into the algorithm but then the
question she didn't just be let's scrap
that algorithm and hide it and never
tell anyone about it and create a new
one the question would be why don't
women have this characteristics that
we've written into you why do we think
those characteristics are important for
a job in our workplace and are they
really important for a job in our
workplace so I think they really should
be those broader questions being us
thank you so if you want to line up and
ask questions we have microphones here
and I think yeah back there as well but
John do you want to respond quickly yes
to filmer I so appreciate what you just
said I might ask you to keep your mark
short if you don't mind just so we have
time for questions everyone tells me
that for some reason good means nothing
unless you define what that good is
right so when someone says my intentions
are good great I'm glad they're not evil
but what are you building for so a
positive future the reason we talk about
human and environmental well-being in
our work is there are ways that you can
say when the environment is not
suffering and it's flourishing and
there's enough water saints Johannesburg
for the next hundred years that's the
the UN SDGs or great things to say these
are models of success same thing we
haven't talked about mental health if
you know the idea of triple bottom-line
people planet and profit profit doesn't
go away and this is one thing I want to
make the point of saying it's not about
being anti corporate it's about
recognizing that people also work at
corporations but if you don't say triple
bottom-line is what good is then
whatever you build will still be built
on top of neoliberalism classical ways
of deeming what something is success the
five words this is my last thing don't
worry Johnny the five words that I say
are actually gonna kill humanity are not
something like evil robots or
operation since these five words did we
make our numbers at the end of every
quarter that is what is actually driving
humanity that is not good or bad it just
is so laws that exist
awesome couldn't agree more GDP are
human rights we haven't talked about as
well as being they're the bedrock for
what ethics should be built on but
unless we change the fundamental aspects
of what our key performance indicators
are we will always be slaves to the
bottom line please John so I take out of
that that this is something that we have
to do collectively and by talking about
AI for social good sometimes that can
mask another conversation that could be
had about the system that we all buy in
to invite it and benefit from but can
also change ok first first question here
I think that'll be very important going
forward and unions have long been
focused on fair paying safe jobs for
people and by extension of that what
they're really doing is giving people
access to health care education and
lodging which is what they get from the
income I wonder in the future if unions
we have to evolve rather than focusing
on maintaining jobs and move towards to
advocating for a ubi and universal
health care and things like that how do
you see unions evolving in the future -
not necessarily fight for jobs but
perhaps fight for the well-being of
workers or student to be maybe not
workers thank you and I'm gonna ask if
you don't mind keep our questions or
answers short just so we can get through
as many people as we can and I just want
to say excellent question we are
involving in that way I just personally
I am NOT a fan of the ubi I think it's a
scapegoat I think it's way too easy for
people to say oh just get rid of all the
jobs and give people ubi we work for
many other reasons then then just earn
the money we are moving strongly into
the direction of also pushing for as
John was talking about measuring
well-being how can we promote well-being
as an index of success rather than
profit we're also working the tea you
see in England the three-day weekend so
we're changing a lot of that but I think
you're right in questioning this and one
of the things that I'm working on right
now is actually a way to electronically
and virtually reach out to the members
also the unusual suspects
and actually here watch what is the main
priority is it pay is it mental
well-being is it the three-day weekend
so really in that way engage broadly in
this as much as possible Thanks thanks
Christina
yep back there first question I'm not
sure we can hear okay I'm gonna ask you
sir to speak really loud I think really
deeply about these issues they just
taught an ethics class to computer
scientists at the University of
Washington this past winter I guess my
question is I mean we talk about
computer science ethics and I'm gonna
focus on that issue because this is a
room of technologists I mean that that's
kind of the lever that we can pull here
it's not really policy to the degree we
might desire and I wonder about the
normative lens that we're using you know
what ethics what is the valence and so
I'd ask all of the the panelists maybe
to speak a little bit to that and and
particularly to ask you know what's the
call to action you know we're not gonna
implement policy changes necessarily at
the moment this is a lot of people that
care about AI and social good you know
how do we drive the conversations how do
we implement the classes at the
University in particular if you know a
bet is you know striking ethics
guidelines from their accreditation it's
a bit of a long question but I
appreciate it thank you Sophia can I ask
for your opinion on that so I just want
to say that I know what it's like to
work in a company every day and have
responsibilities and goals that you have
to accomplish so what is the call to
action what are things that you can do
in the room because of course what we're
talking about our big issues of
structural inequality and the ways that
public policy dictates that and of
course those are big issues we have to
work on together but we also want to
figure out welcome to you in our
everyday
so one of the things I think immediately
coming out of this session is you can
organize these reading groups and there
is a whole host of us who are writing
books including people who are writing
papers on this panel and people that we
work with and collaborate with and you
can start reading immediately because I
think we certainly want to see you know
this kind of lifelong learning
commitment and we maybe even be
education or deeper education into some
of these conversations that I don't even
think we can do justice to in an hour
but we have great reading lists of
things and of course many of us would
come and have conversations in companies
and start thinking through the nuances
so that in your own kind of mental
logics of thinking through your work you
might ask different questions which is
of course what you know in my work
I write you know I wrote a book about
Google in essence and Yelp but I was
bringing to it different questions many
people have written about Google and are
writing about digital platforms but they
weren't necessarily thinking about it
from the perspective of those who are
most vulnerable or who have the least
amount of power in pushing back on some
of these company decisions so you'll ask
different questions if you ink put
yourself into different conversations
and I think that will also lead to
different kinds of products or again
limits that you might impose on
yourselves you know if that Oppenheimer
effect and that you know I'm sure John
can speak to this as a historian and a
technology better than I but you know
many of the people who worked on the you
know worked on some of the most a there
are modern weapons that were that we're
dealing with now you purely pursued
those as scientific exploits and left it
to policy makers to deal with the
repercussions of that but what would it
have been like if engineers themselves
had said you know what autonomous
weapons too far we don't want to
participate in the making of so
there are things I mean it's
technologists don't have to abdicate
their own moral compass and can
certainly engage with the kinds of
evidence gathering that we're all trying
to do to support you in that so yeah
it's really quick just because I have to
pitch but it's free we have fourteen
standards working groups were those
discussions you just talked about we
need you engineers and technologists
they're free to join you don't have to
join I Triple E standards form the basis
for policy and law
so please join that work we need people
in this room I really liked thank you
joining to comment Sophia you made about
the transatlantic slave trade emerging
simultaneously to the enlightenment that
if we just focus on the good we may
ignore that there's a lot of harm being
happening simultaneously so in fairness
we've had two men ask questions if it's
all right I might have you ask our next
question just we have some yeah how
appropriate because I so I'm gonna my
question is kind of going back to the
beginning of the talk when we were
talking about bias I am you know from
the US and of course Silicon Valley has
a serious diversity problem and so we
were talking about biases that are in
the data set I kind of want to talk
about the biases that may come with the
engineers in the developer you know 65%
of the Silicon Valley is white men and
in Silicon Valley a woman actually means
a white woman due to the fact that less
than 10 percent of the women are women
of color so my question is considering
that implicit bias obviously is
happening within organizations and also
within the rooms where things are being
developed do does the panel think that
diversify in the workforce in the
workers or developers could have a
positive impact on the decrease of some
of the biases that we see in the
products that are being developed and
maybe talk to possible solutions that
are thank you if you move it and
Cristina maybe a few my first you need a
microphone sorry that's really an
excellent question and and I absolutely
agree that you know diversity in Silicon
Valley is a problem
and and of course you know the
viewpoints and the subjectivity of
whoever is developing a product will
necessarily dictate how that product
functions what features are considered
important and this is not just for ratio
diversity this is also for
neurodiversity this is also for people
with disabilities etc but I I want to
push back a little like while I agree
for sure that worker diversity is
important
I actually think much more important is
leadership diversity because I think a
lot of times when we talk about
diversity in Silicon Valley we'll focus
on the engineers we'll focus on the
workers but I actually think that given
the the structure of power in
organizations diversity in the c-suite
is actually more important and I think
we really haven't scratched the surface
of that because there's even much less
diversity when you get you know into the
higher echelon of Silicon Valley so I
think we really need to keep that in
mind and consider that that's also a
problem thanks Christina do you want to
make a quick comment yeah very very
quickly on now I really wanted you know
I think it's excellent excellent
question I agree so much on this we
mustn't put so much responsibility on
the workers all the time but for those
of you who in who do develop in this
room and this leads back to a discussion
we had at a panel on earlier this week
every time you produce something every
time you're working on something get a
group of diverse people to discuss it
with you get your friends who are
philosophers who are priests who are
teachers who are doctors who are nurses
whatever my priest friends are is busy
yes get them you know talk to them about
it get their angles do a 360 on this and
check for any of the unintended
consequences of what you're doing and
how
then you could discuss this and then get
your leadership I really appreciate that
to do the same okay
I'm sorry we're gonna go to one in the
back and then we'll come back to you
framework of indicators and I was
wondering how could this community
really helped contribute to using AI for
developing better indicators but really
also acknowledging some of the
challenges including like how AI tools
are not equally distributed around the
world and how maybe they're really how
do we think about agency and so that
these sort of indicators are gonna be
contributing to a more sustainable
future thank you yeah John yeah do you
want to talk about your work and maybe
just for who in the room is familiar
with the sustainable development goals
just show of hands okay just because not
everybody is good you want to describe a
bit of what they are and that what you
guys are working on I'll do my best I
won't give them due shrift but the
United Nations has 17 sustainable
development goals that by 2030 if
they're achieved can have a pronounced
positive effect unilaterally
holistically around the world many not
just from one sector or people but also
the environment so I lead work at I
Triple E there's a one of our standards
it's called 7010 would love to get you
involved the whole idea of the standard
is to both educate engineers data
scientists programmers who may not know
about the UN SDGs and indicators beyond
GDP and then teach people that really
what indicators are if you don't know is
statistics machine learning and AI could
do some of the most brilliant
forward-thinking work to help improve
well-being by improving statistical
modeling so I'm also executive director
of a program called the Council on
extended intelligence that was founded
with the MIT Media Lab great people like
Joey Ito and the other thing too we
haven't talked about much here is the
bias of where your
based most of us in this room are from
the west ethics in the West is largely
about Plato and Socrates and what's
called eudaimonia which is awesome I'm
the big fan it's flourishing but if you
go to the east there's Confucius if you
go to the Africa there's a boon to
ethics and in a boon to ethics there's
the idea of the gift economy not the gig
economy but the the community focus of
non-western traditions often says can I
make sure that your well being and the
environments well being if we want to
get non anthropocentric meaning not just
human focused and think about the the
environment in a holistic way how can I
make sure the Earth and others are
benefitting more how can I make sure
their well-being is increased before I
even think about my own it's a lovely
way to think so the indicators that
exist beyond the SD cheese there's the
OECD better life index butonce Gross
National Happiness
they're all numbers that are saying how
can we measure people's actual
flourishing long-term physiological
mental and other aspects of well-being
so long answer except to say we'd love
to get you involved in the work we're
doing if you want to talk to me after
now it's a fantastic question and how
many how many countries have signed on
to the FT geez I don't know 9 countries
yeah the SDGs are fantastic also the
thing about the SDGs is holistic
indicators be careful because some
people will say like well this indicator
is dangerous because this country in
Bhutan there were human rights issues
every country has human rights issues
period every country is not perfect but
GDP one thing to remember is what it
doesn't measure is things like education
women caregiving right so it's at such a
myopic one focus these other indicators
are saying let's at least experiment to
see what things we should also be
measuring and that they have to be down
holistically not just these three of the
SDGs or what have you
thanks Ron these people are also
available these these scholars and
movers and shakers are available to come
to your organization if you feel moved
and want to kind of continue this
conversation sir thank you for being
patient your question to you great panel
just a comment I think in terms of
impact and bias we place too much
emphasis on the algorithms and explain
ability and and I think that's important
for us for the community develop
them but for the people out there in the
world it doesn't really matter that much
I mean how many people here can explain
how toilet works raise your hand yeah
you wonder - right so I think we're
better off if we play more place more
emphasis on the data and the training of
the data so we could regulate the
training and you know one idea would be
to have datasets there that these
algorithms were tested on are these
systems to make sure there's no bias so
let's say there's a bank you know it's
giving out loans and is using a certain
algorithm and regulators can come and
check it every week or randomly where
the specific data set and if the
algorithm shows a biased and the license
will be taken away so I think there are
alternative ways that are not just
focusing on on the techniques and
explained ability thank you so who and
your questions when you're when you're
using a data set whether you know how
its source to show of hands who here
would like to have more information
about the kind of okay okay yeah that's
good much for that and we can help so if
you want to respond could you hear the
question I think it's to ask the
questions about the training data
certainly we need to be thinking about
that and maybe you know I would just
take it to the next logical step which
is to say it's not just the output of
the algorithm and where it's pointed but
might we think about what this algorithm
could do to mitigate social inequality
or social injustice which is a I think a
little bit different than thinking
through your Bible for me it's to
imagine the world where there's been
five questions what every bias toward
and more biased against and not only
people much more complex lot of
questions because of course even
whatever your neutral set is or your
your objective neutral standard thank
you that you're reaching for is still
reflective of a position of power and
who gets to decide
I don't think integration you have
unbiased algorithms because I don't
think it's a realistic objective and I'm
not sure that it's worth our time I
think it's much more interesting to
think about how our digital technology
is at multiple layers of development
whether it's in the software error and
the training and the kind of the machine
learning or whether it's in like the
more material implement here's my column
of thinking about the environmental
consequences of this and the reverb
that's involved whether it's local
miners your my walls that go into
microprocessor chips that are necessary
for all electronics all the way through
the big factor and connection progress
the kind of planned obsolescence it's
part of our electronics and then the
e-waste that comes from it and the
people who will have to contend with
that and whose Sydney's and whose water
and whose lands will be poisoned by the
disposal of such so it's actually a
really big environment that we're
talking about and of course I think
training data is part of it but maybe we
might also say you know the more we
think about automating and machine
learning and training the more material
resources that actually is tied to you
in the world and of course that's those
labor practices are quite colonial their
brother neo-colonial if you study the
history of kind of how what's happening
in the global south for example with
respect to you how minerals are
extracted and waste is disposed of our
electronics and I think again this gives
us a different set of questions about
what are we doing and why are we doing
it and who is benefiting and who is
really going to continue to lose in that
process those are the questions that I
think a lot of social scientists are
asking right now including the people on
the panel thank you okay I want to make
sure you both get your questions asked
so can you maybe just each asking that
well I'll have them answer
yeah I'll just try to be brief you can
speak we can hear yes I'll just try to
be brief thank you panelists the all
these perspectives
amazing and I appreciate them a lot I
just want to ask we talked a lot of
different things that sound like we want
you know unilateral efforts that to fix
some of these problems from changing
legislation to change in corporate
actions and strategies as well as to
doing new things that aren't even
happening yet and I'm just curious if I
could get even a brief comment from each
of the panelists of what do you think is
the key strategic thing we should be
doing should it be focusing on
government and social institutions like
putting people and two standards
organizations getting new legislators
and new regulators and that have these
ethical perspectives maybe is it in the
short-term like getting private sector
to act more responsibly and having
people in these AI roles that have sort
of a limited and very needed skill to
push and make responsible actions and
diversify their leadership or is it to
build new institutions and have people
potentially use that power and leave
roles and create new companies and
oversight organizations and things I'm
just curious what people think given the
wide breadth of things I've heard great
question and sorry the person mind you
yes because your question is well thank
you also my question is you know John
mentioned are we driven or did we make
our numbers being a chief driver for
private organizations for governments
etc and I know there's a lot we can do
with AI for social impact my question
then is you know how do we convince
these private organizations or
governments who are driven by the bottom
line knowing that hiring ml experts is
expensive guys are expensive and you
know what data cleaning is time
intensive how do we convince these
organizations that they should you know
put the dollars put the resources in
even though it might negatively affect
their bottom line because sometimes
because the planet needs to be saved
because we care about people's
well-being that's not what everyone
actually is making decisions based upon
and it's sad but it's true
all right great questions can each of
you maybe do very one-minute responses
that all right who wants to start
so I'll try to be a very brief first
directly to your question I think we do
have to rethink that as a society what
we determine is value added by a
corporation so that actually goes to law
because most corporations by law have to
provide value to the stakeholders so if
by law we redefine what that value can
be right so if we write it but by law
the corporation can't do things that are
detrimental as a society just to give
financial value to the stakeholders then
that changes the scenario quite a bit
and then to in response to the other
question in terms of what a what can be
targeted efforts I think it's
multi-pronged I don't think it's any to
one strategy I think there's education
and that's education of current
lawmakers called current policymakers
but also education of the people who are
coming up who will be the engineers and
the developers and that education in you
know for me really entails a high ethics
concentration like making that a
fundamental part of the teaching of
engineering and our software development
so with that out very brief comments are
sorry because yo-yo ma is I see the two
questions are really related when you're
young lives in the building so we go no
I see the two questions are really
related and I want to thank you for them
both I would say all action is good
action in this in this not necessarily
but in this in this drive for a I'm for
social good some of us can do political
action you guys can ask the questions
around the holistic s-- of your work
others can do this that we just need to
do something and I dare you know let's
make it happen let's do something in
hashtag it making it happen let's spread
that vibe because I think that's what's
needed and in relation to does it pay
well the market rewards what pays so
let's change what pays let's change that
I mean the market was created by people
and
people talk about the market as being
emotional and all of that as if it was a
person itself is ridiculous we can
change the market and trust me I'm
meeting Moody's and the rest of them all
the time we can do it we should do it we
need to pressure for it
John's final comment Sophie I'm sorry to
get off the stage but comment my comment
is I'm a huge fan of yo-yo ma yeah I'm
just sucking up I think a question I
want to leave you with too is why is
market the fundamental question that
drives humanity and our future markets
are also a convention and an invention
if you read Adam Smith's second book
it's called the Theory of Moral
Sentiments and it actually reflects what
virtue ethicists say around the world
that if you want to compare ethics
traditions virtue ethics is essentially
the instantiation of the golden rule
which is not just don't do bad stuff
it's do unto others as you would have
them do unto you the real opportunity
for me is why we're just asking why our
machines might be sentient when we
aren't also asking what is it about the
values that we want to take to our kids
anybody here a parent look at your kids
and when you get older look at your kids
and think is everything I'm doing today
about helping save the environment
mental health and other aspects have
thought my kids will flourish not just
making a profit thank you okay so it
sounds like today we've learned we've
talked about the importance of calling
companies to make sure there are tax
properly to challenge and problems
problematize the claims of being good
and and trying to hold people to account
to make sure that real good is
accomplished you can join the I Triple E
standards initiative of that sounds of
interest to you you can check out books
online so would you tweet some
recommended readings or each panelist
and I think in some total this is a
vision of the future that we're talking
about this particular get filled gets a
lot of press in terms of promoting a
vision of the future you help articulate
that future you have a lot of influence
in telling this story so please leave me
in thanking there's all of our wonderful
panelists and welcome yo-yo ma as well